[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport teil von mir und das
sind die wichtigsten themen von heute
es läuft nicht rund beim schimpfen
während die nachfrage weiter sinkt
warnen ärzte man solle omikron nicht auf
die leichte schulter nehmen
sturmtief mit gewaltiger kraft an der
küste reißende fluten bei berlin stirbt
ein fußgänger durch ein umstürzendes
wahlplakat und
match für die tennisgeschichte rafael
nadal gewinnt die australian open und
kommt jetzt auf so viele grand slam
siege wie kein spieler zuvor
auch heute wieder ein neuer corona
höchstwert die sieben tage incidents
liegt jetzt fast bei
1157 tendenz weiter steigend was dagegen
sinkt ist die zahl der impfungen wurden
kurz vor weihnachten täglich noch rund
eine million gemeldet waren es am
freitag gerade mal
380.000 das impf ziel der
bundesregierung wird so nicht erreicht
julia schröter hat details
zum impfen in den bauch eines a400m der
luftwaffe diese ungewöhnliche aktion
haben am wochenende am airport kassel
die bundeswehr und die johanniter auf
die beine gestellt die technik lockt
das bemühen weiter möglichst viele
menschen zum impfen zu bewegen ist groß
allerdings das ziel der bundesregierung
bis ende januar 80 prozent der
bevölkerung mindestens einmal gegen
korona geimpft zu haben ist nicht mehr
zu schaffen bis gestern haben lediglich
75 7 prozent die erste spritze bekommen
73,9 prozent waren doppelt geimpft gut
die hälfte der bevölkerung
52,6 prozent ist doppelt geimpft und
gebucht hat
das risiko sich mit omikron anzustecken
war noch nie so groß wie heute warum
also sich jetzt nicht gleich absichtlich
infizieren davon abraten ärzte klar ab
denn auch ein sogenannter milder verlauf
kann einen richtig krank und ins bett
zwingen unter anderem sind fieber husten
schnupfen und kopf und gliederschmerzen
möglich außerdem bauchschmerzen und
erbrechen auch schwerere verläufe mit
intensivbehandlung sind nicht
auszuschließen das risiko ist zwar
geringer aber es ist nicht 0 und vor
allem viele ungeimpften noch ein
beträchtliches risiko und man geht
zusätzliches risiko ein von longo wird
das heißt lange beschwerden zu haben
herzrhythmusstörungen
experten raten impfen lassen und weiter
versuchen sich nicht anzustecken ein
angepasster impfstoff gegen omikron soll
im frühjahr da sein
ein toter mehrere verletzte und hunderte
einsätze für die rettungskräfte dass es
die bilanz der sturmnacht in deutschland
sturmtief nadja ist über den norden
europas hinweg gefegt seit gestern abend
traf es dann vor allem den norden und
den osten deutschlands
umgestürzte bäume wurden zum
hauptproblem für rettungskräfte an der
nordsee kämpften sie mit sturmfluten an
seinem stern berichtet der sonntag nach
der sturmnacht der gesamte norden in
deutschland kämpft mit den folgen hier
ist es die weser die jetzt durch die
straßen fließt im bremer stadtteil
vegesack
das wasser steigt schon sehr hoch wir
sind selber wassersportler und kennen
uns sehr gut aus und dass es so stark
dass sie mal nicht auf das schon
faszinierend
faszinierend und lebensgefährlich
windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 130
kilometern pro stunde
entwurzelte bäume zertrümmern autos und
stoppen züge hunderte einsätze für die
einsatzkräfte
das ist beelitz in brandenburg ein
wahlplakat wird zum tödlichen geschoss
ein fußgänger stirbt im sturm eine
stunde lang kämpften die ärzte um sein
leben bei unserem eintreffen wurde die
person bereits von ersthelfern
reanimiert wir haben dann sofort dabei
unterstützt kurze zeit später ist der
rettungsdienst tier 1 getroffen hat dann
alle weiteren maßnahmen übernommen
trotz alledem ist die personen leider
verstromt
gefährlicher wind gefährliche fluten in
hamburg holt die feuerwehrautos aus dem
wasser und rettet die zwei mann
besatzung von einem schiff festgefahren
unter einer brücke der wasserstand der
elbe war schnell gestiegen schwer
verletzt wurde hier niemand das schiff
komplett zerstört ganz in der nähe heute
nachmittag der hamburger fischmarkt
schon wieder überflutet an diesem
sonntag nach der sturmnacht im norden
von deutschland
die spd bleibt trotz internationaler
kritik bei ihrer haltung keine
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine das
wäre das völlig falsche signal sagt
parteichef klingbeil stattdessen müsse
man jedes gespräch führen um einen
diplomatischen ausweg aus der krise zu
suchen und einen krieg zu verhindern das
ganze interview mit dem spd-vorsitzenden
können sie gleich nach und sehen in
berlin direkt jetzt zu einem
staatsbesuch den es so noch nie gab ein
israelischer präsident zu gast in den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten
empfangen wurde präsident herzog in abu
dhabi vom außenminister
danach traf das israelische
staatsoberhaupt den kronprinzen und
faktischen herrscher der emirate al
nahajan erst 2020 hatten sich israel und
der golfstaat angenähert und
diplomatische beziehungen aufgenommen
es war eine der grössten tragödien
zwischen katholiken und protestanten im
nordirland-konflikt der bloody sunday
vor 50 jahren
britische roller an weg sie schossen auf
unbewaffnete katholische demonstranten
13 staaten erst jahrzehnte später gab
die britische regierung zu dass ihre
soldaten das feuer eröffnet hatten wie
tief die wunden heute noch sind zeigte
sich beim gedenken diana zimmermann
genau diesen weg sind auch ihre brüder
schwestern und eltern gegangen vor genau
50 jahren durch das nordirische terry
ein bürgerrechtsmarsch unbewaffnet der
in einem blutbad endete 13 meist sehr
junge männer starben als die britischen
soldaten das feuer eröffneten unter
ihnen brei die gallaghers 20 jähriger
bruder
der horror verlässt dich nie ich kann
immer noch die lauten scharfen schüsse
der britischen soldaten hören
sind heute hier aus denselben gründen
die vor 50 jahren wahrheit und
gerechtigkeit
wir fordern eine anerkennung für die
betroffenen verliehen
klar die sunday war einer der dunkelsten
tage in unserer geschichte musste der
damalige premier david cameron 2010
eingestehen
eine untersuchung hatte festgestellt
dass die schüsse nicht wie behauptet
selbstverteidigung waren doch keiner der
britischen soldaten wurde jäh vor
gericht gestellt nun will die regierung
und johnson sogar eine amnestie für alle
bürgerkriegs taten erlassen gegen
erbitterten widerstand von opferfamilien
auf beiden seiten
bekommen wir nie gerechtigkeit wäre das
in london oder in berlin passiert würde
es nie vergessen werden das war ein
massaker an zivilisten
aber sie sollen es vergessen er ist seit
1998 herrscht ein zerbrechlicher frieden
in nordirland doch durch den dreck cit
wurden alte konflikte wieder angefacht
und immer noch gilt ohne gerechtigkeit
ist der weg zur versöhnung besonders
schwierig
und jetzt tennis mit hammer sieg von
rafael nadal bei den australian um zu
sagen nach rückstand zum rekord mit 2 0
sätzen führte sein finalgegner daniel
medwedew aus russland dann drehte nadal
die unglaublich spannende partie der
einundzwanzigste grand slam sieg des
spaniers ja und eben eine für die
geschichtsbücher
kein profi vor ihm hat das geschafft
rafael nadal setzt sich nach
unglaubliche energieleistung an die
spitze der bestenliste dabei hatte dani
medwedew gegen den im vergangenen herbst
und winter wegen einer fußverletzung
ausgefallenen spanier schon wie der
sichere sieger ausgesehen mit diesem
ballwechsel sichert sich der
weltranglistenzweite aus russland den
zweiten satz im tie break nachdem er
bereits den ersten mit 6 zu 2 gewonnen
hat
doch nadal beweist mal wieder
unvergleichlichen kampfgeist holt mit
gesteigertem risiko satz um satz auf
nach fünf stunden und 24 minuten hat
nadal dann tatsächlich matchball zum 7 5
im fünften satz sein
einundzwanzigste triumph bei einem
grand-slam-turnier
auch in abwesenheit des weltranglisten
ersten novak djokovic eine wahrhaft
sagenhafte leistung
fußball profi max kruse wechselt
überraschend mit sofortiger wirkung von
bundesligist union berlin zum liga
konkurrenten vfl wolfsburg wo er vor
sechs jahren bereits für eine saison
aktiv war zum wintersport auch heute gab
es beim skisprung-weltcup im hessischen
willingen wegen wind problemen nur einen
durchgang bei den frauen und da heute
landete katharina althaus auf dem
zweiten rang hinter der slowenin nica
krishna und anschließend bei den männern
da war der wind besser deshalb auch zwei
durchgänge mit einem starken karl geiger
der oberstdorfer holte sich mit einem
sehr guten zweiten sprung nicht nur den
zweiten rang hinter dem norweger marius
link sollen dann auch das gelbe trikot
zurück als führender im gesamtweltcup
ein ausrufezeichen vor den spielen in
peking
das was sonst dankeschön geht noch der
blick aufs montag seite zeitweise
kräftige schneefälle bis ins flachland
später in lagen unterhalb von etwa 500
meter wieder zunehmend in regen
übergehend im westen und süden starker
bis stürmischer westwind im bergland
gefahr von schneeverwehungen
ein bis sieben grad
und die weiteren aussichten sehr
wechselhaft vor allem am alpenrand mit
sehr vielen neuschnee christian sievers
begrüßte im heute journal um viertel vor
zehn wir sagen tschüss bis morgen
wünschen ihnen noch einen interessanten
sonntagabend und empfehlen dazu
natürlich theo koll und berlin direkt
vielen dank da war weg